well how did you get started in
filmmaking I think I was born with a
camera in my hand I remember ever not
wanting to make movies the thing that
was interesting was i was when i was
little i thought the actors kind of made
it up as it went along so I wanted to be
an actor and then as I got older two
things happened one I realized I suck at
acting ha but two I began to learn oh
there's a writer and a director and as
people behind the camera and to me that
became more interesting i rather tell
the story then you know until somebody
else's story through my performance
whatever i just i found that was much
more where i was i was geared to so when
i was 11 i started directing movies but
when you were 10 I understand something
very fascinating when i was 10 i
auditioned for for the low for the lead
role of danny in the shining they were
casting out of Denver where I lived
because Kubrick you know the film takes
place in Denver butter in Colorado
better casa de Denver so they kids could
send and headshot so it's in the head
shot and I got an audition so I met with
Jen Harlan in a hotel and proceeded to
bomb an audition for Kubrick and I can
proudly say that I've been rejected by
Stanley Kubrick you're gonna get
rejected get rejected by the best but
that's uh yeah that's what happened so
going back to that experience now that
you cast people does there anything that
you take from that or no that was just a
ten-year-old going on a cool vacation
with his parents well no I think the the
casting for the shining vacation it was
just literally down to like the hotel
downtown Oh for the shining they were
casting kids who weren't necessarily
actors so there wasn't really like read
this page day I knew was a horror movie
my mom knew Stephen King's work and then
she read the book because of the because
the audition was coming and they knew
who Kubrick was like all this is gonna
be really spooky movie too high news I
didn't know the story exactly that new
is a haunted house thing in a scary
hotel and I was total scaredy-cat as a
kid always hiding under the covers from
the blob or whatever and I was worried
that if they knew I was easily scared
that they wouldn't cast me because they
wouldn't want to work with somebody not
realizing of course there's a thousand
people around in lights in your face
Oh is should be in a dark room and I'm
going to get scared they're not gonna
want to work with somebody to get scared
who can't just pretend to be scared but
it's actually scared so I went into
thinking to myself I'm not going to get
scared matter what they do i'm knocking
I'm going to put on a brave face so the
guy started by asking me what scares you
trying to get a fear reaction out of me
because I'm a kid and I'm thinking I'm
not going to get scared matter well
nothing scares me nothing scares me
think oh come on what scared you well
maybe sudden movements he kicks over a
chair and I don't jump but he goes
you're bullshitting me and I like no no
I mean I'm totally talk myself out of a
job I just been the scared little kid
that I really was instead of trying to
act brave I might have had a shot but no
when I audition actors I tend to work
with actors so I you know I don't need
to play tricks with them I just sit on
the sides and tell them apart and they
come in and they give me their take on
it so they act I what I was doing
you